um
right so uh today is going to be our
first i believe of two problem sessions
covering dynamic programming
um iphone dynamic programming is one of
these interesting parts of an algorithms
class where like somehow
the people that are really good at it
are completely disjoint with the people
that are good at all the other parts the
algorithms
class so for some of you guys that might
be promising uh
and for others maybe a little bit less
so uh so maybe we'll spend just a minute
or two kind of reviewing the basic ideas
we're going to apply
uh in these problems because they all
follow more or less the same
template although of course as usual in
606 we like to put some
interesting window dressing around it so
that it's not totally obvious what
you're doing
and then we'll do a bunch of sample
problems um right
so let's let's talk a little bit about
dynamic programming and the the basic uh
idea here so dynamic programming is kind
of a funny outlier in six double six in
that like
for example in the data structure is
part of the course we learned
like what you know struggling to think
of a data structure like
like a useful you know like trees and
arrays or whatever
and these are actually things that you
can code like if you if you look in cmos
plus
like there is a there are well plausibly
could be
an implementation of a tree in there
some way um and so these are like useful
algorithms that you could maybe even
read the pseudo code and there's a
universe where you really do translate
that pseudo code into something inside
of your laptop uh
dynamic programming is a little bit less
so this is more of like a meta i don't
know if you call it a meta algorithm or
a problem-solving
approach or what um but it's not like
you somehow say i'm going to apply the
dynamic programming algorithm to
this problem but rather it's sort of
this big class of things that all
follow a similar template or or sort of
approach to thinking about problem
solving
um which i think sort of explains why
actually in some sense the
last couple lectures that you've seen
and i guess if i'm getting the
the time sequence of our course right
the next couple ones that you will see
um and the problem sessions actually
start to coincide in the sense that
like when eric was teaching you guys
dynamic programming
how did he do it well he didn't like
write down well he sort of wrote down
some template for dynamic programming
but then we just did a bunch of sample
problems
and that's exactly what we're going to
do today uh so somehow all of these
things are just going to converge
uh in in this part of our course because
dynamic programming
it's really more of a way of life than
any particular
algorithm uh and this is a pattern that
i think you see a lot in advanced
algorithms
like for example in my universe
numerical analysis like when you talk
about the adm
algorithm it's actually totally useless
algorithm what matters is applying it to
a particular problem uh and and this is
a sort of i think a more mature or
grown-up way to think about a lot of
things uh in algorithms right the
pretty soon this sort of general purpose
stuff
that's useful all the time i think i
think it starts to disperse a little bit
in favor of different patterns and
mechanisms that you're used to thinking
about
so there's my 10 seconds sort of
philosophical introduction to what we're
doing
during which i've managed to chase this
table
across the room you know i played
i did college on the west coast and i
thought i was going to be a music major
and there's a piano master class where
we forgot to put the little
clips on the wheels and i there was an
earthquake and
i just thought i was really nervous
because the piano was literally slipping
away from me
and i can never think of that that
chopin nocturne in quite the same way
um but in any event uh uh in dynamic
programming uh
eric laid out for you guys a particular
sort of set of steps uh that are sort of
a useful
problem-solving approach uh in the
dynamic programming universe
uh in today's problem session i'm going
to try and help you guys translate a
little bit from
this template to what it means to
actually write code to implement a
dynamic programming algorithm because i
think
it's a little easy to forget that here
but
uh on the other hand on your homework
when you're writing out
answers to algorithms problems it's
perfectly fine to follow this template
even letter
i guess literally letter for letter and
answer each of these questions and then
sort of the remaining
glue that you need to actually write the
code is not terribly uh
exciting from an algorithm's theory
perspective um
so the basic idea here is that there's a
lot of different problems that can be
written
recursively in some sense uh certainly
we
we've encountered many of those in this
course in fact i think the bias in the
way that we've
presented algorithms that don't have to
be recursive is to write them in a
recursive way
um and and the point here is that
when you have a recursive call and you
repeat something
you know you give the function the same
input more than one time
you might as well remember what you got
the last time you saw that input
and then you don't have to do that
computation again really in one sentence
i think that's
roughly the logic behind all these
dynamic programming things
yeah so there's no reason to be too
redundant with lecture uh
for just sort of the 10 second overview
i think that
there's an example which is
simultaneously good and misleading which
is this fibonacci
sequence uh it's good in the sense that
the logic of dynamic programming is
really easy
it's bad and that the runtime is kind of
weird to think about
um but remember those your fibonacci
sequence looks something like
f of k equals f of
k minus 1 plus f of k
minus 2. and if you look at your sort of
recursive call
tree here right like let's say that i do
k equals 4
right then it's going to call you know
my function f is going to have to
evaluate it
at three and two and then the three is
going to evaluate at two and one and so
on
and the thing to notice is that when i
call f before
or rather f of 3 here if there were 3
somewhere else in my tree i get the same
number right so in particular
f of 2 and f of 2 both of these are
going to take some amount of algorithmic
work but if just the first time i see a
2
i have a little piece of scratch paper
and i say ah anytime i see
uh k equals two just return this number
rather than doing recursive calls
then in effect if there's any subtree
underneath this thing
uh i i've just pruned it from my tree
right
and and and so that's the basic uh logic
here
uh and that's basically the the paradigm
that's going on in this this
sort bot uh acronym
uh which is is uh you you first take
your problem and divide it into sub
problems
that is mysterious why is this board
moving
um oh there's a phone in my pocket i
bumped against the wall
uh
i'm not used to this classroom um right
uh
yeah so the first thing i want to do is
to write my my problem as sort of
this sort of form notice that we've done
this a lot in this class we've written
things recursively the difference
here is the the sort of argument that
goes into recursion is typically
maybe a little simpler than you know
like putting some giant
data structure inside of there or
something like that right so for
instance
merge sort you could write in this
paradigm i guess we covered that but
it's probably not the most natural way
to think about
merge short then we need to relate our
sub problems to each other
so for instance in the fibonacci
sequence problem i just gave you the
relation that sort of what defines the
problem
incidentally this is what a model for
the
reproduction of rabbits i think if i
remember reading the history of the
fibonacci
sequence um
and then i think to me the most not
necessarily unnatural but i think the
thing that maybe is hardest to translate
to an
algorithm if you're thinking about
writing code is to say oh man this is
going to be a problem
uh this idea of topological uh order
the basic idea here is that like if f of
one depended on f of two
and f of two dependent on f of one i'd
be in a lot of trouble right because
somehow my tree would never
converge for one thing if i made these
recursive calls and
i'd never be able to memoize or kind of
remember a value
when i move on right and so the idea
here is that there's some ordering of my
sub problems so that i can build up a
solution
and there's sort of two dual ways to
think about why that's useful
so in the memoization universe
right what do i do i just add an if
statement saying you know if i've
already
evaluated f okay return it that's
perfectly fine
um the other thing i can do is if i
write my sub problems in topological
order
then i can sort of go in the reverse
direction and build up
my memoization table so for instance uh
for
uh the fibonacci sequence problem i
could do f of one and then f two and
then f of three and f of four
all the way until i get to the k value
that i actually wanted and those are
just duals of the the same coin
they're exactly the same approach of the
memoization version sometimes you can
prune out
some problems that you didn't actually
need to solve so for instance maybe this
was f of k minus seven
uh and so i can like skip a few indices
in my array
i don't think typically that has a big
effect on run time for the problems that
we've seen but it could
um plausibly uh in some universe so i'd
have to think about
a problem where that that makes a
difference um
right and then i think the bot part of
sort bot is a little easier to think
about
you have to make sure that this
recursion has you know a base case like
when is this
thing going to stop that's exactly the
same as just any recursive
algorithm um the o for original
i think is a little bit retro retrofit
to to make sort but sound nice but i
think the
idea here is that you need to go back to
your original problem and make sure that
it corresponds to
one of the function calls that you've
written and all this complicated stuff
hopefully that's a reasonable
characterization and then finally the t
uh
is more you know these are for
describing your algorithm the last one's
for analyzing it
um and again the the the bot part of
sort bot almost applies to
anything we've done in six level six
like you should always analyze your run
type
um okay so in any event that's my
10-minute version of uh the last couple
lectures uh and i think
more or less enough to uh get us started
with some sample problems here
sorry i couldn't help but i like to
teach things okay so uh right so
in our problem session we have a few of
the homework problems from last year
uh to go over um if it makes you guys
feel any better i got myself all balled
up on one of them last night while i was
preparing for today and i
i look forward to doing that in front of
all of you guys now
uh right so i'm afraid of this so i'm
going to go to the next part
um okay so in our first problem uh sunny
studies
this was somehow you know the like cute
naming conventions we have in 606 got
really meta
in this problem because there's a
problem about tim the beaver uh but as
we all know
uh tim is mit backwards so like he
happens to fit into this goofy
game that jason likes to play in in
writing homework problems anyway um
but it's also the mit mascot anyway
i got very excited um right so so what's
going on in this problem
so tim the beaver has kind of an
interesting
uh you know mathematics i think you
would call this a martingale if you flip
the coin a little bit
when you solve this problem but uh
luckily tim the beaver is a
deterministic
uh kind of a guy and he looks at the
weather outside
and if it's a temperature t apparently
tim the beaver is okay with boiling um
the higher the temperature uh the
happier
tim gets so this is a first derivative
uh kind of a phenomenon
in particular uh on a on a given day if
i have a temperature
t uh tim the beaver has
two things that he can do to change his
mood apparently tim the beaver's mood
never
stays fixed it always goes up and down
um
in particular you can either uh
go outside
in which case uh the happiness increases
by t
okay or uh he can stay inside
in which case his happiness decreases
by t okay so every day tim the beaver
uh he wakes up he he
i really want to say that he checks for
his shadow but that's that's a gopher
right
um in any event he he wakes up in the
morning he checks the weather
uh and he makes a determination does he
want to go outside or not and if he goes
outside
he gets happier by an amount that's
equal to the temperature
if he stays inside he gets less happy by
an amount that's equal to the
temperature by the way i think our
solution is perfectly fine if
temperatures are
negative here in which case i guess
everything would kind of flip
uh intuitively but there's no reason to
get too hung up on that
but of course there's a twist here so
tim as with many of you has n days
until his final exam
and he's worried about studying yeah so
uh in particular
um he never wants to go he's you know
he's
come up with a personal resolve to never
go outside more than two days
in a row yeah
so right
and so the question is right because
that way you know he has to stay inside
and study at least one out of every
three-ish days
okay so the question is how can tim
maximize his uh his happiness
incidentally that's you know machine
learning sometimes they call that
minimizing regret which i always found
to be like a very sad way to
think about algorithms when there's a
totally dual version but but tim's an
optimistic guy he wants to maximize his
happiness
subject to this constraint that he
cannot go outside more than two days in
a row right so like if i go out on
monday and tuesday
i have to stay inside on wednesday yes
i think there's no effect to his
happiness there's no effect to his
happiness when he stays in
uh no one says with a decrease in
happiness when t o
when t is negative
that's not actually going to affect our
problem at all
sure yeah i can fix this live uh and
this is what happens when i do the
problem myself before looking at the
answer and then don't check it closely
um fine so uh let's let's change that
i like this problem better uh somehow
psychologically but
that's okay um right so uh jason
correctly points out that if you
actually read the problem
uh what's what's uh asked there is is uh
slightly different that when he goes
outside his happiness increases by t
if he stays inside his happiness does
nothing right so
um it stays the same
my apologies so um tim tim the beaver is
a particularly optimistic beaver his
happiness can only
increase in time assuming he lives in a
climate with positive temperatures
okay now i think i've got it right now
cool
let's see if i can still do this
yeah i think basically nothing changes
okay that's great
all right we're gonna do it um
okay so right so uh the question is how
do we uh solve this problem
uh and and thankfully i think we put the
easiest problem first uh and in
particular if we're following our sort
by
paradigm here um somehow there's there's
a
set of sub problems that are staring us
in the in the in the face that's all
right i'm looking for
uh in particular uh
well there's sort of only one index in
our problem which is what day it is
so the obvious thing to do would be to
say can we
figure out the maximum amount of
happiness for day say
i to the last day by the way if i do
that i'm using the prefix version of my
problem
uh ah suffix version of my problem i
could also
uh do it the opposite way and work from
the end back in um
maybe if you have time all the way at
the end we'll do the second one but it
doesn't doesn't really matter
okay so in particular um just to add a
little bit of notation
uh let's say that uh t of i
is equal to the temperature on
day i okay
uh and now um we're going to make a new
thing
which is going to be the actual variable
we want to compute this is going to be x
of i
which we'll write is the
maximum happiness
that you can achieve if you only
consider the calendar
uh from day i to day n
i guess inclusive okay uh
incidentally just for convenience we'll
assume that x i is equal to zero if i go
past the end of my
uh array um so i think it's kind of a
typical thing to do in these
dp algorithms okay
so the question is can we actually come
up with a recursive algorithm that
computes x i uh using this nice uh
sort of topologically acyclic uh
way of of thinking about our problem the
answer is obviously yes
i wouldn't be here today um and and so
you know in the absence of a smarter
idea let's let's just do the
the toucan sam approach here and follow
our nose
uh and see if we can just uh write our
problem in terms of other ones
so in general let's say the that tim the
beaver wakes up on day i
he has basically two decisions that he
can make
right he can either stay inside or he
can
not stay inside he can go outside uh
right so so let's let's just basically
uh handle these three cases so in case
one
he stays inside
well now what happens to his happiness
well according to my revised version of
this problem nothing
right so uh in particular um
what do we know well if he stays inside
then he has
any decision he can make tomorrow it
doesn't matter he can go inside and go
outside
whatever because by having stayed inside
he's earned himself
two free days of going outside if he
wants right
so in particular in this case we can
convince ourselves
that this is true
in our i think yes
um right so in other words uh well he
gets no utility for today he wakes up
tomorrow and he can make whatever
decision he wants
okay the second thing he can do
is go out
this is where things get a little tricky
right can i just
do like you know take t i
and add it to x i plus one what goes
wrong
ah maybe you go out three days in a row
right you
you somehow you have to remember that
right uh and and so that's where
things are a little bit of a a headache
um the in particular if i go out
today and tomorrow i can't go out the
day after that
um and somehow if we just uh dealt with
this one case as t
i plus x i plus one we wouldn't remember
that right and that's a problem
so instead what we can do is think of
there being two subcases
right so what we're going to assume is
that not only does he go out today
but that he's free to go out tomorrow
and we're going to kind of make that
recursive assumption as we move down our
array
so if we do that well now we have
case a in case b so in case a
he goes out today and he stays in
tomorrow
okay so what happens in this case well
by the way i'm using this kind of weird
arrow notation i don't know if this is
good or not but essentially the point is
that i'm keeping track of cases
and then eventually gonna want to have
to take the max over all of these things
so i don't like the equal sign because
somehow that's a little misleading
um right so in that case while he gets
the
utility of having gone out today
tomorrow he stays in which means that
the day
after tomorrow he can do whatever the
heck he wants right he has he has free
reign
so i can write that
using this recursive call uh
similarly
uh right so
i'm getting the hang of this
sorry this is way too entertaining for
me i can play with this board all day
um okay so in in in case to be
he goes out today and he goes out
tomorrow
okay so he's a party animal
he is an animal and he's going out a lot
um right so in that case what happens
well he gets that he gets uh
today's utility he gets tomorrow's
utility uh
the day after he has to stay in so we
might as well skip it
and then he can do whatever he wants
the day after that okay so
if we go back i guess technically
we should revise our definition of x a
tiny bit
that it's not the maximum happiness well
we can convince ourselves that it's the
same thing
but really it's not the maximum
happiness for day i through
n it's the maximum happiness for day i
through n under the assumption that he
has permission to go out on day i
right and that's really what's going on
in our our recursive
set of calls here okay so does our
recursion
make sense here cool all right
so uh let's see here so if we're
following our sort bot
i keep reviewing papers that use the
word paradigm a lot so i feel like i
should do that
so what is t is the topological order
notice uh that um right
x i only depends
on larger eyes
so in terms of our topological order the
dependence graph is really simple right
it's just a line
um so remember that you can think about
topological order or you can think about
being acyclic graph those are equivalent
we covered that in this course i kind of
like thinking about acyclic graphs
um right so x1 depends on x2 depends on
x3 it depends on x4
that graph has no cycles so we're good
um right what's our so
next we have to come up with our base
case for our recursion
notice that the way i have chosen to
solve this problem
is uh by calling future indices
which means that my base case sits at
the end of my array right because that's
sort of like the lowest down on the
recursion train
the recursion chain is what it's going
for but i kind of like the recursion
train better
um in particular on day one
well if he has permission to go out on
day n um
he can do one of two things so you can
either go out or not it doesn't matter
right uh so in particular we can say
that that's
the max of zero or t of
n remember i didn't tell you that
temperatures have to be positive
yeah maybe he uh he's a celsius kind of
a beaver
okay uh right and and then in addition
to that
um for convenience
notice that like there's a universe
where i look beyond the end of my
array in my recursive call here um so i
should probably think about a few extra
x's
uh obviously the utility of going out on
a day that doesn't exist is
zero uh so we can say that x n plus one
equals x and plus two
equals zero okay i've managed to use way
too much space for one simple
algorithms problem
[Laughter]
right so now uh we need to do the o and
the t uh
so what's our original problem
well remember that he wants to maximize
his happiness starting on day one
um so uh our original problem
is just x of one um
or is it so remember that tim the beaver
this is you know
your instructor is very sloppy when it
comes to actually reading the problems
as you saw at the beginning
a second mistake for which i would have
personally lost points
where i did solve this problem on my
homework is that it didn't ask for just
the maximum
amount of happiness that tim could
achieve that's not very practical
for your everyday beaver uh but rather
um
he wants to know the actual plan he
wants to know what days he can go out
and what days he can't
yeah and i haven't actually told you how
to do that right i've only told you how
to compute
x which is just the maximum amount of
happiness
if i were you guys i i think this is a
perfectly reasonable simplification
that's like a warm-up problem to solve
like i would argue less of a warm-up and
more
the crux of the problem uh and then
going back and making sure you can
convince yourself that you could
actually reconstruct the solution um
my way of solving this was ever so
slightly different from the one in the
problem but they're equivalent
which is to say i can make a second
array i mean i won't write it down
because i'm slow at writing
that just says on every day whether i
took option one option two a or option
two b
right and now i can reconstruct my plan
very easily right so i look at x1
if i took option one uh then i stay in
and i look at
you know day two if i took option 2a
then i can label today tomorrow and the
day after
oh wait uh yeah that's right i can label
today's choice
tomorrow's choice the days after choice
and then look three days later
and recurs that way um or option b
is kind of similar right so a reasonable
way to reconstruct uh the actual set
of what days you go out and what did you
go and is this to remember as you do
your memoization or whatever
uh whether you did option 1 2a or 2b and
then it's pretty easy to reconstruct
from there
maybe i'll let you guys convince
yourselves of that at home or in the
last eight seconds if you happen to be
the two audience members that i have
uh and then finally um
right we need to do our time thing and
most of the time arguments here
follow more or less the same pattern
which is you count the number of sub
problems and the time per sub problem
you multiply those two things together
uh and you get your runtime we're going
to see in one problem
on this problem set that's not quite
right because we have to account for
some pre-computation
but uh in this case it is right so
right so let's see what are our sub
problems here well essentially
i guess i didn't actually say it but you
have to take the max of these three
values
um this is the max of three expressions
which have a constant number of plus
signs and
lookups and memory and all that good
this stuff so
each sub problem
takes order one time
how many sub problems are there well
there's i guess
n plus two uh max if you want to be
conservative about it
uh so in particular there's order and
sub
problems right so all i have to do is
multiply these two things together
and my algorithm takes order and
time
and that's our solution to problem
number one
any questions so far yes uh-oh
uh when i was thinking about problems
beforehand i was wondering
could you use base cases right now we
have two different kinds of base case
uh a base case for x of n and the base
case for things after
can i remove the first one and add an x
sub n
plus three equals zero as well what
would that do
could i remove the first one and add an
x of n plus
three yeah i guess that's fine
sorry that's not a particularly helpful
answer for the people watching on video
my answer to this question you can't
hear is yes um
right so uh the question to uh repeat uh
was you know this base case was somehow
kind of complicated looking
to be fair it's the one that i was given
written out
but that's okay um but the the question
is is this truly
necessary in particular can i get rid of
the xn
case and instead add a third day
past the end of time uh which also has
value zero
and if you kind of look at that plus
case
b i think you uh
or rather case a i think you're
convinced well case a and b
for that matter you can convince
yourself that these are equivalent right
um
that's absolutely right so so i could
add a third day after the end of this
thing
which also has value zero or by the way
i could just say
in my code if n is big you know if i is
bigger than n
return zero that's the same thing um
yeah and then i guess i don't have to
worry about that xn case yeah these are
the same
you know to each their own fabulous
question any any others uh that i can
answer while we're at it
cool all right so that's problem one
writing too big i don't like this big
chuck you know
okay so problem two is the one that got
me all hot and bothered yesterday so
let's see if we do any better uh
in front of people because that's
usually the best way to improve uh
problem-solving skill uh right uh so
in problem two which annoyingly is also
probably the most practical uh
problem on on this problem set
essentially you have
a uh i suppose i should write some stuff
down
right so in problem oh i used the wrong
side
two uh you have an operating system
menix whatever
which is a uh you know apparently it's
very simple
oh i get it doesn't mean i have to like
it
um right so
in menix um yeah
uh apparently the only thing that my
operating system can do
is uh compute edit distance between
files
um and it wants to do so efficiently so
we have that a file
is a sequence of strings
um and i believe we say their length
is less than or equal to k that's going
to come into play
a little bit later and the strings are
basically just lines of the uh
the different files uh so there's
three different ways that we can change
a file um
so here are the changes we could do
uh change number one uh is to add a line
change number two uh is to remove a line
and change number three uh is to swap
but a caveat um for
this this uh interesting model of
what's cheap and what's not uh is that
apparently swapping two lines is cheap
because they exist in memory like maybe
i'm
i don't know using like a linked list or
something to store
files and so swapping two pointers isn't
so bad uh
but inserting and removing a line is
hard because i don't know memory
allocation is expensive like
you know menix is actually operating on
clay tablets and
you know i can chop my clay tablets into
different slices and just pick them up
and swap them and that's fine but
you know if i want to add a line in my
file i have to go to the
tigris and euphrates and pull out the or
whatever it was the
eucharist and the tithradis and pull out
a
you know stone it's a lot of work to
make a new line or to
dispose um right so these are expensive
and this is cheap
right and so the question uh that i'm
trying to say
that i'm trying to say and that the
problem is trying to ask
is that you are given
files a and b
um with uh n lines each
uh you wanna know what the uh
the minimum number of non-swap
operations it'll take
uh so in other words the minimum number
of times you need to add and remove
lines
to transform a into b right
essentially with low cost
and in fact uh just to be nice i think
that's actually kind of a critical hint
uh in this problem um we give you the
runtime
and i'm gonna kind of ignore it in my
answer notice that i did something wrong
and then go back and fix it this is
different from the way the answer is
written where
you know god came in and said like oh we
observe that we're probably gonna need
this thing so we're gonna go ahead and
do it here
uh i think that's that's maybe not
representative of the logic here so
um right so the the runtime here is k
and plus n squared the first thing to
notice
there's a k here
yeah and and so someday uh we're gonna
have to compare strings
right because that's what k is and i
think that's sort of sort of the hint
that's implicit in this problem it's
easy to miss
uh and and and so indeed what we're
going to notice is we're going to look
at our solution and say well wait a
second if we didn't
incur a factor of k we must have done
something wrong um
and indeed that's going to be the case
but uh
it's only a minor uh fix to change it
there's another important distinction oh
i'm sorry yeah and
um right when i swap things uh they have
to be
adjacent you can't write at the bottom
of the board
um that's supposed to be adj
for those watching at home uh but they
have to you can only swap lines that are
adjacent
um as they appear in their original file
i'll say it out loud rather than try and
write it because it's going to take like
the rest of the lecture to do that
okay any other things i've forgotten
this high likelihood i'm bad at this
okay
so uh this problem is annoying and
and and it's not actually annoying it's
actually a relatively easy instance of a
very well-known dynamic
program plus a tiny bit of additional
stuff which is called edit distance
um in fact i think if you guys are
looking for intuition on this problem
you might google that one first um
as sort of a what was that oh in fact
you're doing a recitation oh that's why
it's not totally unreasonable to come up
with the answer here
even better um but even if you hadn't
you know this is just another dynamic
programming uh problem that's just like
a little bit more
annoying than your than your average uh
programming problem
uh now the solution written out in the
course notes works from
sort of the last line of the file
downward in some sense
up upward whatever
um i like literally lost two hours of my
life trying to think about
editing files from the end up and just
getting myself
all upset and confused so so here i'm
going to attempt and do it in the other
direction
and probably introduce a bunch of
mistakes in the process so
what do we do in dynamic programming if
we don't know what else to do we we do
sort sort stuff sort bot uh and so let's
do that here
uh so in particular what are our sub
problems this is a little bit funky
especially even before we do the s of
sort back let's think about our problem
a little bit
um let's think about like what it
actually
means to edit a file uh because this is
what helped me
sort of think about the right answer
here which is to say
you know so so what's going on i have
like two documents you know
this is document a this is document b
right each one of them is composed of a
bunch of lines
and i'm basically trying to turn a into
b and the only thing i can do
is like scribble out a line insert you
know just hit the enter key
or do a third thing where i kind of like
swap two uh things that are adjacent to
one another this is the only thing i can
do
and the way that i like to think about
this problem
kind of an annoyance here which i think
is a typical annoyance in dynamic
programming problems which is that
the order of operations suggests that
this problem is a lot combinatorially
more difficult than it is right because
like okay let's think about how i
actually edit documents like i spend two
thirds of my day editing bad grad
student writing
is like you know i'm like jumping all
over the place between different lines
like first i
delete this line then maybe i go to the
bottom of my document and delete some
other one
that would be a big problem from a
dynamic programming perspective
i can't jump all over my document
because keeping track of that whole
edit history is going to be somehow
combinatorially
ginormous right i'm not you know the
track changes button in microsoft word
i want the minimum number of changes and
if i have to recurse over like
all possible edits to every single line
in any order that's an awful lot of like
factorials and two to the ends floating
around
that i don't want to have right and and
so that's the sort of crux of of the
challenge here
uh is to organize my approach
to editing these files in a way that
doesn't require me to have to
do this sort of combinatorial jumping
all over the place and i think it's also
the one where
this sort of like i know jerry kane at
stanford talks a lot about the the the
recursive leap of faith
you know like somehow dividing your
problem into organized sub-problems
that's that's
that's really where where the challenge
uh lives here
so if i were a more organized phd
advisor the way that i would edit
a file um or a clay tablet uh i guess
in this case um would be linearly right
that like i might as well do whatever
the heck i'm gonna do to line one before
i move on to line two
right and like at the end of the day
like even if i did stuff in a different
order you could convince yourself that i
could always order it in such a way that
like all the edits that i do to the
first line kind of
happen before lines later in the
document
uh with the possible exception of this
swap thing
um but we'll see that that somehow
doesn't matter and
and moreover if i do an edit i might as
well do the edit to make
things better right like there's no
reason to just start like willy-nilly
inserting and removing
lines um i might as well always do an
operation
that that improves stuff and so thinking
about that sort of logic
leads me to the to a particular
way that i might write down my s uh my
sub problems here
which is to say that i'm gonna think
about editing my document line by line
so in other words like once i've dealt
with line one meaning that i've found
some way to mess with it and make it
match line one or the other guy
i'm just gonna kind of think about
removing it and then
thinking about the rest of the document
you start saying ah-ha that's then it
sounds like recursion
and that's right that's how we're gonna
solve this problem okay
so in particular here's going to be our
our thing i'm going to do a slightly
different one in the solution so you
guys should all be vigilant
which is i'm going to write x i j to
be the min work
to convert
i'm not a python programmer but
hopefully i got this right um
i colon is going to be everything from i
to the end of the file right so in other
words this is the
suffix version of our problem um
and uh into
b j
like that okay um so in other words like
i have like a little it's kind of like a
video you know like i think about tetris
you know once
once you get that full line of blocks
you can just throw that line of blocks
away and the whole video game moves down
there's somehow something very similar
going on here which is the second i've
managed to get a match for line one of
document into line one of the next
document
i'm just gonna like throw it away and
pretend like i have two documents with
one less line in them
now the thing that got me all hung up
last night
my original problem assumes that both of
my documents have the same length
but here i'm not making that assumption
right
and essentially what we're going to
figure out is that that actually doesn't
matter a whole lot that
if i end up with one document of length
k and
well i shouldn't use k one document of
length l and another document of like
zero
what's the amount of work that i should
do to convert well
l right because my only choice is to
insert a bunch of of lines
in one document by the way or delete a
bunch of lines from the other those are
dual to one another they're exactly the
same
i'm philosophizing a lot because i'm
also convincing myself that my answer is
okay in the process
okay uh right so this is gonna be our
set of sub problems and now
we have to do um the uh the r
right we have to relate something we
struggle with in the math department
sometimes um
and essentially uh the way that i went
about this uh
is to just do a billion different cases
of all the possible edits that i could
do to line i and line j
and that's perfectly fine in this
problem i think the problem is is a
little slick and
the way that they've written the
solution they've convinced themselves
that like some things are equivalent to
others and removed him
but he didn't have to as long as there's
a constant number of cases you're you're
golden
ponyboy uh so in particular uh let's
think about some cases
so first of all if line i
matches line j of my document
remember that it's not really line j
it's like making a document that just
happens to kind of start at line j
right it's like taking scissors well
then i can match them with zero cost
right because the beginnings are in the
same place and i can move my tetris game
down one
and that's perfectly fine so uh right so
case one i think is the easiest one
which is
if a i
equals b j
right then i can just remove that line
from both documents and move forward
uh in which case i'll use my same goofy
notation
i'm going to get that x i j
well i'm going to just increment i and j
and keep going right
like that cool okay
so what's something else i could do i
could delete a line yeah
so what happens uh
okay um so
case 2 is delete
a i right that's a different thing i
could do to line i
well now what do i have to do i have a
document on the left hand side which is
one line shorter and on the right hand
side nothing changed
but deleting a line cost me a dollar
right
so uh in particular i have that x i
j well what happens well i got rid of
one line
right but i had to pay
okay let's think about some other things
um you could delete
bj
this case actually isn't in the solution
because it turns out to be unnecessary
um oh i'm only allowed to edit a
oh in that case i don't have to delete
bj i really didn't read these problems
very closely that's my bad
this would have made it much easier i
really should read these things
um cool so that like eliminates half of
the cases of my notes
fabulous incidentally you could
do these things on the other direction
and it really wouldn't change this
problem a whole lot
uh sorry you know i have this bad habit
like when i'm reading research papers of
like reading the research paper i wanted
to be there instead of the one that's
actually on the paper uh and somehow
it's a very similar phenomenon here
okay right so uh great so i can only
edit document a which makes this problem
way easier than what i was worried about
uh fabulous in that case
bananas um what's our third case here
well um let's see i could also
insert a line um
let's see so what what ends up happening
there so i can only edit
document a so that makes my cases
different than the ones i wrote down on
my notes
um
sorry okay so uh
um okay so if i insert
let's do this live yeah okay so if i
insert a line at line i
i might as well make it match bj there's
no reason not to
right like i might as well kill off one
element of b while i'm at it
yeah so if i do that what ends up
happening
well i still have to match line i i've
just kind of moved it lower in my file
but i've in essence killed one line in
file b
by making it match this new line that i
inserted in my notes because i thought i
could edit b
i said ah okay i can just delete the
line and b instead and somehow logically
that's a little easier to think about
but but these are these are exactly dual
to one another um
so in that case i have x i j
well i still have to deal with a i
haven't gotten rid of it but i've
matched line j
so i paid one dollar for uh
inserting a line and now i have
that because i've gotten rid of a line
in in the other file
if i stopped here by the way i would
have edit distance but
um unfortunately for me i have one
additional case which is
mild irritant as they say which is that
i can swap
right first of all can i always swap
i mean i can but if i swap two lines and
they still don't match the lines on the
right-hand side
i'm kind of host right because i'm you
can convince yourself that in the next
step i'm gonna have to delete
something anyway swapping was free if i
swap and delete that's the same thing as
just deleting so it doesn't really
matter
um so in particular what that means is i
might as well only check the swap
if it actually helps me yeah so in other
words
if i have a
now you have to be a little bit careful
because i'm swapping so if the next guy
in a
equals b the current guy and b
and the current guy in a
equals the next guy in b
well now i can swap this guy and kill
off two lines of my files while i'm at
it right
uh so in this case uh i get that x
i j well swapping doesn't cost me
anything and i killed off two things
so
that's the uh the the recursive so if i
were to write this out on my homework
what should i do
well i shouldn't i mean probably if you
use this arrow notation i don't think it
would be a big deal but but really you
should add a line at the bottom
saying that you know i can choose to do
any of these things so really my
recursive call is x i j
gets the min of all of these
uh 1 2 3 4 expressions that i've written
here
okay
what if i have the first condition but
not the second one
ah so that's a great question
yeah so the question was like okay what
if i you know
i can match the next line but not the
current one
well there's two different things you
could do you could either make another
case for that that's perfectly fine
right in fact you could do that you
could do you know that i match the
second condition not the first one like
whatever you can just
enumerate as many things you want lungs
are all true and there's a constant
number
um alternatively you convince yourself
that that actually is unnecessary here
because
a different so that's like swapping
but then one of those two lines is still
a mismatch so you're gonna have to
delete something in the next step
so you might as well just delete first
rather than then
swap and then delete uh and and so
that's why that case isn't
isn't necessary exactly
exactly so if you swapped and you killed
a line then in effect i think it's a
combination of case one and case two
here
if you kind of expand your recursion out
but if you're having trouble convincing
yourself of that
that's fine just add a case here yeah
any other questions i'm going to ask
quickly because i this problem makes me
nervous
sure yeah okay in the worst case if if
we've done something wrong you can
certainly add another
case here um i'll think about it at home
okay so uh since i've managed to
pontificate too long let's let's keep
moving here
oh yeah the problem is it might have
[Music]
been
then that's not okay yeah because at the
end of the day
the the files have to agree like you
have to match b to a
it's cheaper than doing two deletes into
inserts no no but the
the swap and the lead is illegal because
you have to use both
lines that's a condition in the problem
oh i'm sorry that's a better answer um
so jason points out that if i swap thing
i can't delete it
um because the way the problem is
written so that effectively removes this
case
otherwise i think i guess eric is
ah sorry i've managed to totally botch
this which is totally unsurprising
um yeah so so i think the problem also
states that like
if you swap the swap has to be useful
um and that's why this this additional
case that eric is asking about where you
swap
and then you match one line um but not
the other is unnecessary
you might be able to relax that by just
adding a case here but since the problem
doesn't ask it i'm not gonna think about
it okay right so
under all the assumptions this problem
that i didn't read but are very
important to solving this problem
correctly
uh uh i believe we really have uh uh
written down all of our cases here um
okay so let's let's continue with our
sort bot
uh paradigm um so now we have
all of our recursion the topological
order here is a little bit
trickier than normal right because now
you've got a two-dimensional array
but it follows a pattern that's pretty
typical here which is that
x i j only
depends on on other x ijs
with um higher
i plus j right so i think about my graph
of sub problems
it always you know if i wrote this in a
2d matrix it always kind of points down
and to the right maybe
which is what's making it uh acyclic is
a very typical pattern in the sort of
two-dimensional
dynamic programming problem all right so
let's see here
sort bot so we need our base case
this isn't too bad because essentially
when you have boring documents
um they're very easy to match to one
another uh
right so in particular uh
for any i if i'm at line n plus one in
other words i have a blank document that
i'm matching to
document i well how much work do i have
to do
you'd be a little bit careful this is
where the suffix version of this problem
is a little bit more annoying than the
prefix one
or if i manage to swap those backward
again um
that in particular the remaining number
of lines looks like
n plus one minus i
right um which is different than like in
the problem it's just i
because they're working in the other
direction in the solution matter
and similarly you need a second case for
those two here right so
you have x n plus
one j is going to be
n plus 1 minus j
cool okay so
we're going to continue with sort bot
here
um right so what is our original case
kind of by definition
uh is is x one
one or zero zero depending on how you
index
uh and then finally what's our runtime
well uh let's see there's n plus one
squared sub problems and of course
that's equal to
order n squared the sub problems are
just a constant amount of work
so they're each with constant work
so our entire run time is order and
square
and hopefully by watching me be confused
in front of you and think through this
problem you too
will see how the problem-solving you
know procedure can happen uh in your own
disorganized brains
okay so that concludes our our sort of
treatment of this this problem here
that i think is the hardest one so the
other two thankfully are much easier to
to think about i thought but i never
liked that at a distance i remember
seeing that in undergrad algorithms
getting confused
okay so uh the next problem uh problem
three here
uh deals with saggy mimson
and she has a bunch of blocks and she
wants to stack them on top of each other
as one does and as a
young structural engineer she has a few
criteria on her problem
let me go to the right page in my notes
here
right so uh so this is problem three uh
so we have that block b um
[Music]
i uh has size that looks like with
w i by
height h i by length l i
i remember getting confused in
elementary school about the difference
between width and length all the time to
me those always sounded the same
but it doesn't really matter because
she's happy to uh rotate her cubes
anyway that
that she pleases there's a key detail
which i did remember
to actually read in this problem uh
which is that she has at least
three of each
type um where type here means that i can
i can permute
these three numbers any way that i want
because that's the same as just rotating
a block
but anytime she has one block that's
like one by two by three
she has at least two two more in her bag
somewhere
okay um
oh 1 times 2 times 3 is equal to 6.
thank you
apple watch okay so uh
that's odd so she can orient her block
any way that she wants meaning she can
rotate it
um uh and any any in any fashion that
you'd like
and so what we're trying to do what we
want
is the max height
um where she's stacking uh the her end
blocks
i suppose i should stay there and blocks
uh so she wants the max height that she
can achieve
but just to be kind of annoying um
or because again she's very concerned
with structural stability she lives in
an earthquake zone
she would like uh with the condition
um that each block is strictly supported
uh on the block beneath it right um
so in other words like if this is the
base
of one block then the next block that's
stacked on top of it
has to be strictly contained in the
block uh
below it right so
the problem makes sense have i omitted
any critical details i don't think i
have this time this one's a little
easier
oh yeah so and she can't do anything
crazy she can't like do like a weird
you know like balance it on his edge
kind of thing um which is
eric is absolutely right could actually
give her a taller uh
tower than you could get if you're only
allowed to rotate blocks 90 degrees
i don't think the problem states that
explicitly but this isn't a trigonometry
class so i think we're in good shape
okay
um right so so that's our our basic
problem here
this is one of these problems that like
is going to be a dynamic programming
problem but again
similar to many of the things that we
saw in lecture it's not totally obvious
how
right because somehow she has this big
disorganized
bag of blocks you could imagine a
universe where there's two to the
n different things she could do right
she for every single block she could
decide
whether or not to put it in her stack
and then she has to do a bunch of other
work to verify whether
she can stack them uh while supporting
the strict support condition or not
so initially that seems kind of annoying
so
what we have to do which again is pretty
common to a lot of these problems is
placed some order
on it i mean that both in the entropy
sense and also like literally we're
going to order stuff
um and and in particular uh we'll see
that this problem has a lot in common
with that longest common subsequence
problem that we saw in lecture
increasing subsequent sorry um
right so here's some some
observations about our problem which are
going to help
um first of all
when we stack our blocks we might as
well
always align the shorter side of the
block on top to the shorter side of the
block underneath it
right um
let me draw a picture of what i mean
so let's say i have a really a block
whose base kind of looks like that
and then another block which is also
rectangular
that i sit on top of it like that
then notice i could so in this case the
shorter
edge of one block is aligned to the
longer edge of the other notice i can
rotate it 90 degrees
and it still supports on on one another
so there's never a case
you convince yourself with just a few
inequalities um where i don't kind of
always put the long side parallel to the
long side of the guy underneath it
and the short side parallel to the short
guy underneath it does that make sense
cool so that's observation one
observation two can i ever like let's
say that maggie
actually sorry sat saggy
actually had not just three blocks of a
type but like 25.
so she's just like has hella blocks
right she's uh
my question doesn't matter the answer is
no because um this word here
is really critical which is that there's
strict support right so your block only
has so many faces
right and in fact um by by observation
one
really all that matters is which of the
three types of faces is sitting on top
right because we can just always rotate
right so there's three configurations of
every block
so at most can any one configuration
appear more than one time
no because of the strict support
condition right otherwise the rectangles
would match up and that's against the
rules
yeah um so in particular
oops the number after two is the number
after one is two
which looks like that um okay uh
right so so in particular um there are
only three
orientations
right this is just which of the three
edges of the block is the one that's
that's going away from the floor
the normal to the ground and moreover
uh each can appear
less than or equal to one time that's
good because it limits the size of our
problem
uh and finally um
[Music]
oops well i collapsed the the two of the
cases in my notes into one case here
um but that's okay uh and in fact notice
that the problem tells us that she has
at least three of each type
so in a sense if the problem
um if you observe a one of a block you
might as well just throw away the rest
because
you know that you can use it at most
three times and she has three
of that block we can't use it more than
three times so in sense that's just
surprise
information okay right so
um this allows us to
to put a little bit of order here
because notice that when i look at the
stack of blocks here
what do we know if i look at the length
of the long side and the length of the
short side in the plane of the ground
those numbers have to decrease on every
level of my block
right they can never increase that's
what the strict support condition says
combined
with observation one actually even
without observation one
um which is which is good news right um
so this is what's going to allow us to
impose
order on our problem namely that we can
sort by the edge lengths
because we know that we have this
support condition okay so let's
let's fill in some details of our
algorithm here
okay so
right so originally already we can see
that our list of blocks
is kind of useless because the width
length and height values
are sorted in ways that don't matter
moreover
if we have more than three of a given
block that's somehow not super useful
um so instead of that um
let's uh without loss of generality
let's assume
so w-l-o-g
here um we can always uh take our block
uh and assume i'm gonna do this slightly
different from my notes
the width is less than or equal to
the height um
is less than or equal to the length okay
so so every block
if this isn't the case i could go down
my array of blocks and sort and
sorting a list of three numbers is
constant time okay
um right so
what does this allow me to do well i'm
going to say that a block type
actually is an ordered set where the
third number
is going to be the axis that points up
and the reason to do that is that we
know that we can never use that more
than once for any type of a block
yeah so now i'm going to make a new list
of blocks
with a capital b because i like blocks
and it's going to look like the
following so if with
so if w is less than h is less than l
then i'm going to take every block and
duplicate it three times
notice that i might end up with a list
with like nine times of every block but
we'll we'll fix that later um uh
right and it's gonna look like the
following
which is that okay i'm gonna have
w-i-h-i-l-i
this is like describing a way to stack
my block right because it's saying this
is the short side
this is the long side this is the
vertical side
yeah and there are three cases right
where any one of these guys can be the
vertical side right so there's
one let's say that the h is the vertical
side
then w has to go before l so it would be
w
i l i h i
and uh a third one where the third guy
is w h is less than l so that would be h
i
l i w i and those are all the different
ways that i can sort of
orient uh these blocks in my stacking
assuming that i
um impose condition one for convenience
here
i'm going to make a new list of blocks
where i take every block in my original
set and i just duplicate it three times
this way after i sort its coordinates
right and now um well what do i need to
do well for one thing this thing may
have too many blocks i might have a
block that's that's repeated more than
one time and i know i can't do that
um and moreover it's gonna be convenient
to have this sorted because i gotta
stack these guys eventually
yeah so i'm going to sort
uh that list and i want to do it i can
never say this word
lexicographically meaning that
i'm going to sort on the first
coordinate and then the second and the
third
lexicographically um notice this length
is 3n if i had n blocks to start with so
this entire thing takes order n log
and time which is important to account
for
and then i can remove duplicates
i'll let you guys convince yourself you
can do this in order end time
an easy way would be to make a second
array uh and just kind of move
and only add stuff when when you you
didn't see the same thing before
okay and finally now these are ordered
in a really nice way right because i can
stack my blocks
by only ever looking to the right in my
sorted list
right assuming that i'm stacking from
the top of my tower down
which is i think sort of uh what's
what's going on in this thing
okay so now finally we can do our sort
bot
um and i might do s and rnt
and then allow you guys to think about
the rest because as usual i'm talking
too much
okay so now
this is starting to look like a
subsequence problem right because
essentially
when i stack my blocks if i use this
block here
again if i'm stacking from my tower from
the top down
all the blocks that can sit underneath
this one have to be
farther to the right in my array because
of the way that i sorted
now that doesn't mean that i can put
anything on the right
underneath this guy but it does mean
that i know nothing to the left can go
underneath this guy
that's that's the way to think about it
okay so
here's going to be sort but so s what
i'm going to say
is that x i here
is equal to the maximum height of my
tower
and i'm gonna taking a little bit of
inspiration from our subsequence problem
that we've already seen
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna force myself to
use block i
we'll see that's convenient
i and possibly
uh just for fun maybe we'll do the the
prefix version of this problem this time
um so now uh
i can use any of the previous blocks
right so i can use the first i blocks to
make a tower
but i'm forced to use block i by the way
i'm from now on when i use indices into
this sorted array
okay um so this is a problem
obviously uh if i could solve for x i
would be done right because i could get
the maximum height
by just iterating over all the x's and
choosing the biggest possible
value here um and the question is how do
i do this uh recursively
um okay so uh here's our uh recursive
step
so let's say that i use block i
well because we we know we have to right
um
so uh in particular right we have uh
oh now i'm seeing why they didn't use
this notation uh in their answer but
that's okay um
let's use another letter to refer to the
third coordinate
[Laughter]
um yeah let's say vi is always the third
coordinate so if i use w h and l and i'm
afraid if i reuse them after sorting
it's going to confuse people
um so v i
is the third uh coordinate
of the is element of my my sorted array
that's fine
okay um right so what is my height uh if
i use uh
x i here well i get some height from v
i and in addition to that i get whatever
i i i stack
underneath that guy so in particular um
i get that x i well i get the height of
the block that i just decided to use
uh and now what are all my cases
well i could decide to do nothing else
like just not use any other blocks
that gives me a height of zero or
well let's see here
i could use the x's but i have to be
careful that i can actually stack them
yeah so in particular
well i need
yeah um i can take
uh an xj value but i got to be careful
that i can stack it underneath
um so in particular um what do we know
well
uh i can do anything from 1
to i minus 1
right because that's sort of the
definition of x i
but in particular
i can stack it on top
right so one easy way to do this is i
can just array i i
iterate through the first i minus one
elements of my array and i just
check my stacking condition for every
single one of them relative to block j
right so in other words
that the the the width uh and the height
or rather the first and the second
coordinate
uh satisfy the strict inequalities that
i need i'm phrasing this sentence
neutrally because i forget whether this
is increasing or decreasing
uh but in any event um so what do i do i
check all of the blocks
that i could possibly stack from the
index of the array perspective i make
sure that i could actually stack them
thanks to the
the size of the current block that i
just decided to add to my stack
um and i move recursively
okay right so this is great because now
we're in exactly the recursive scenario
we want it to be in
right because x i only depends on xj
where j is smaller than i and that is
exactly our topological
uh ordering that we need if you do that
on your homework you get minus
n for large m okay uh
similarly uh what's our base case well
obviously um if i only have one
block i might as well use it yeah uh so
in that case we have
x one is equal to i guess in
our notation here like that uh
our original one it's a little bit
careful because of the way that i've
defined
x because x assumes that i've used
a particular block right so i have to
say well i
i might not have actually chosen you
know the very last block as the one i
want to keep
um so i have to iterate i can say that
really
my original is the max over i of x i
right so one of these blocks has to be
the block on top
i'm just going to iterate over all the
possible ones and find it
and then our final thing to do is the
runtime t
um this one is mildly trickier
than the previous runtimes that we've
done so far in our example problem
in particular uh how many sub-problems
are there well there's n sub-problems
or i'll say order n because i'm always
off by one
right corresponding to each uh block in
my my stack here
but how much time does each sub problem
take at least the way that i've written
it here
um well what do i have to do i have to
loop over all of the possible blocks and
find the one that i can stack on top
of and then take the max so there's a
loop here
from 1 to i i is upper bounded by n
so this is order n sub problem signs
order n work
per sub problem
so at the end of the day my algorithm
is going to be order n squared time and
of course
again i guess i had i promised it and
then i didn't actually do it
to actually implement this algorithm
there's sort of two different ways to do
it right i could
write a recursive call plus a table
right the tables may be initialized to a
bunch of nands
and then i implement this function
recursively but before
i do that i say if the table does not
equal nand just return the value in the
table and otherwise
you know call this recursion or i could
just have a for loop from one to n
and build up the table uh one element at
a time and both of those are are
exactly the same from a runtime
perspective
okay so i think i've managed to botch
that much more than my notes or the
written solution
uh but uh the problem itself is actually
pretty straightforward so if you guys
read through the answer
plus some of the i think actually the
hard parts of this problem were not the
dynamic programming it was all the
observations you need to get there so
that's why i i spent a little more time
there
okay so as usual i haven't left myself
enough time for the last
problem but we have a few minutes and
and that'll be that'll be sufficient to
set up the the
parts i actually found the last problem
to be easier even though
it technically is sort of two dynamic
programs in one um somehow i think the
logic is a little easier
okay so uh
[Music]
i think this is the backboard yeah
that's i was just realizing that this
room doesn't work the same way as the
other one
uh yeah this is embarrassing you know i
spent all day thinking about topology
and
this is like a classic kind of you know
problem in that universe um
okay we'll just erase one board at a
time and i'll try not to write
three feet um wide this time oh this is
probably the one board i shouldn't use
i don't think i like this classroom
okay so right and our final problem
we're given an n by n grid uh and on our
end by end grid
uh princess uh apple uh banana
plum princess plum uh uh
right so here's our basic setup there's
a big grid
of stuff
or maybe a small grid because i don't
feel like drawing and and every grid
square can have one of three things you
can have a mushroom
you can have a tree or it can have
nothing at all
and uh our princess starts here
and she goes she wants to go there
uh and and and moreover uh
there's a couple things that are worth
uh noting here so first of all
um her path is quick
meaning uh that she can only traverse
two and minus one grid
squares
to get from one corner to the other
and apparently she's very into mushrooms
and she'd like to
accumulate as many as possible along her
path right
that's the basic setup here so she wants
to get from the upper left
to lower right and uh in order to do so
uh she wants to take a quick path so she
her main priority is to be efficient but
among the different quick paths
she wants to pick up a lot of mushrooms
it's understandable
and not walk through trees thank you
right so like maybe there's some
grid squares that are marked with like a
tree meaning that you just can't go
there
that's a tree um okay uh
right so that's our our basic setup here
um but the problem does
it takes a bit of a twist right it's not
saying just compute the shortest path so
it should be very much like the last
kind of unit in six double o six um but
rather
uh the question is sort of what is the
number of paths
uh that she can take from one side to
the other
um and what is the maximum number of
mushrooms uh is roughly the question
asking at least what i remember from
reading it last night
that's right so so so she has to take
the most number of mushrooms she can but
there may be more than one path
uh that gets you there that is quick
that satisfies his condition
in which case she wants the count of the
total number of ways you could get from
one coin to the other
why you might ask why not um
okay so right so uh you know so for
instance maybe there's a mushroom
here now there's a quick path
that gets her there and collects one
mushroom so there's exactly one but
maybe if there's a mushroom
there well initially
it feels like maybe she could get two
mushrooms right she could go there
go up pick up the second mushroom and
get back
but we're gonna see that this quick
condition actually uh
allows it doesn't allow you to do that
okay so in fact
it'll turn out that quick paths uh can
only collect one mushroom in this two
three by three
case so there's the at least two
different paths
well there's one two
three uh different ways that she could
collect one mushroom and have a quick
path
okay so the first thing to notice
your instructors are a little bit sneaky
by defining quick paths
basically by giving her no slack at all
right um
and here's the basic observation
notice that in order to get from the
upper left to the bottom right she's
going to have to go down and to the
right
plausibly she could also go up like you
could try and go around a tree
but only plausibly uh we uh and in
particular the question is how many
times does she have to go down
and how many times does she have to go
to the right well she has to get to the
bottom of the grid
right so she's on grid square number one
just go down
in this case at least two more times so
in general n minus one times
she has to go to the right and minus one
times
so what does that mean she has to make
two n minus two moves
and that's a lower bound right so if she
goes up she's going to have to go down
again so it's only going to make it
bigger
right so at the very least she has to do
two n minus two
moves you know down and right
to get from the upper left to the lower
right how many squares does she touch
when she's doing that
was a fence post problem right so she
made two n minus two moves and she had a
place where she started um that implies
that just by moving down to the right
she makes two
n minus one squares
she touches rather so can she ever move
up
no could she ever move to the left no
and that basically is all you need to
solve this problem the rest of it's
actually pretty easy right
so this is the so the basic observation
here is she can only move down and to
the right because if she moved up or to
the left her path would no longer be
called quick
uh and that would be a problem moreover
every path that moves down into the
right
is a quick path assuming she reaches her
target and doesn't hit a tree
okay um so that's the basic observation
and notice that that already basically
suggests it's like
screaming out to you how to do dynamic
programming because literally you have a
table looking at you on the blackboard
right now
and you have an ordering like down into
the right the the
the the is acyclic yeah okay have i
slammed on the board enough times the
first time i taught at stanford they i
got
negative course feedback that i had too
much coffee and was slamming on the
board a lot apparently
um i watched the video later and indeed
that was not wrong
okay so uh right so
uh we're gonna call k
uh this is gonna be the sort of the max
mushrooms
uh she can get going on on the entire
path in the upper left to the lower
right
so we want to know the number of quick
paths that can achieve this number kit
okay so let's do sort by
really fast because i got four minutes
actually a tiny bit more than that
because we started late
okay so uh
now the kind of annoyance here is that
there's two different numbers that we
don't know right one of them is k
and the other is the number of paths
right like the problem didn't tell you
how many mushrooms she can pick up it
does tell you that there's some path
um to get from the upper left to the
bottom right there's not just like a row
of trees
somewhere which
i feel on my commute sometimes but
it doesn't tell you you know the number
that she has to accomplish
um and initially that's that's kind of
annoying so maybe
the first thing that we do is just
compute k like the maximum number
of mushrooms that she can collect on any
quick path
and then we go back and compute that
other count yeah because that would be
one problem-solving approach so that we
could think about a little bit
um so in particular uh let's define
our k i j
to be equal to well we can generalize
our problem slightly and say
what is the number of mushrooms that i
could get on any kind of
rectangle embedded inside of my full
problem right
so in other words this is the max
number of mushrooms or m's for short
on a quick
path to
i j so in other words she always starts
in the upper left but now she stops at
any other grid cell
okay uh
because i'm running low on time no
i'm going to do this way i want to do
this no so we're just going to think
about k
yeah so the question is could we
compute just this value k which
certainly seems convenient like like
you know princess uh plum really she
might as well know her enemy she might
as well know the number of mushrooms
she's targeting if she can if she can
get it
right um so
how could we do this uh recursively
well she has to get to position i j
and from our argument up there she has
to get there by either coming from up or
to the left
right the way we've chosen to write down
this problem so
what are our different cases well first
of all if there's a tree you can't do a
damn thing right she shouldn't even be
able to get there
yeah and for convenience uh we're gonna
find you could argue that it's zero
um we're gonna mark this as a with a
special number and we'll see that that
makes our notation a little convenient
um so one is if there exists
a tree then we're going to say k
i j is minus infinity again there's a
philosophical question there does she
get minus infinity mushrooms if she
is standing on top of a tree i don't
know because she shouldn't stand on top
of a tree
but at least it's it's going to let us
know that something went wrong in this
grid square
in the other parts of our recursion okay
um and otherwise
well what are our different uh cases
here
well she always picks up a mushroom if
it's there she might as well she's
maximizing
yeah in fact i think the problem even
says that she's she's like really new
mushrooms she like collects them
automatically
right um so uh what do we get
i'll use unnecessarily fancy notation
this is an indicator
of whether there exists a mushroom
at position i j
right um meaning this is a one if there
is and there's a zero if there's not
uh sometimes this is uh indicated with a
one with a little subscript but whatever
um and in addition to that she might
have picked up mushrooms along
paths and we know that her path to
position i j
either came from up or to the left right
so uh in other words we know
that she could have gotten the max from
any path ending above her or any path to
the left of her
so that's k i minus one
j which i guess is to the left and k
i j minus 1 like that
and this can be used to fill in our
whole table of k values
in fact since i'm low on time i'll let
you do the
t bot for the remainder of this problem
right essentially
i think the key observation is this one
right obviously when she starts the
upper left you get zero mushrooms
because she's not standing on top of one
the problem says that
uh and this allows us to fill in our
whole table k
so in particular this gives us our enemy
now we now know
how many uh uh mushrooms she should have
at every step of her journey in fact it
tells us a tiny bit more than that
right because it says if i'm at this
grid scale at this particular grid
square
during my path i should have this many
mushrooms if i didn't then something
else
something went wrong yeah um
so the way that the solution is written
they do two pieces of the recursion and
once
you actually could have just solved for
this k matrix first and then gone back
and done
the second half of this problem and
those are are exactly the same
yeah and and when i was writing my
solution this is the way i thought about
it because somehow
i kind of felt like she might as well
know how many mushrooms she wants to
collect before she starts counting paths
that's like a secondary
question you know um and and so this is
one way to do it
so in our remaining negative two minutes
um let's think about the recursion for
computing
remember that we want to know the number
of paths
needed to collect that many mushrooms uh
the maximum number of mushrooms
please let there not be a whole lot of
stuff on this board ah there's not any
stuff on this board it's great
okay um so in particular
now i'm going to define a second thing
that i also am going to do dynamic
programming on
yeah i'm going to say that x i
j is equal to and i'm going to make a
kind of a sneaky
definition uh here which is the
number of quick paths
that end at ij
with now let's anticipate our problem a
little bit
so at the end of the day we're going to
do like x of n comma n because she wants
to end up all the way down to the right
and how many mushrooms does she want to
have now that we know k she wants to
have k of n comma n
mushrooms along the way
it would be kind of ambitious if she
wanted to have k of n comma n mushrooms
the entire path
um but it would be slightly less
ambitious uh
to have k of i j mushrooms because
somehow
that's exactly what we we just uh
constructed in
in the previous thing was it was pass
right so well
the last guy looks like max now we're
going to expect to see some plus signs
here because we're like adding up
how many paths we have okay and now
let's come up with our recursive rule
for
for this uh array x and then we'll we'll
call it a day
so in particular again
one if there's a tree
how many paths are there there are no
paths because i can't get there
yeah so then i j
equals zero okay otherwise there ain't a
tree
and now i have to be a little careful
right um
so i'm gonna write this like a little
piece of code um
you could have written this as a giant
max instead and there are
a bunch of cases uh and whatever
so let's think about it like a piece of
code so
initially i think there are no paths
that get me kij mushrooms that's
perfectly fine
and remember we're going to keep
applying the same piece of logic which
is that a path can only come from to the
left
and up and let's uh uh think about those
two cases
um and by the way we're going to use chi
to equal this kai of stuff that that we
had
in the previous expression right um so
chi is one
if there's a mushroom at this place and
zero if there is not
okay so my path can come from the left
or up i know that it can't come from
up if the number of mushrooms that i got
from up
plus potentially the one that i got here
doesn't align with the number of
mushrooms that i should have
by the kij standard that i have set for
myself
yeah so if i if i want to write that out
in code uh the way i do that is i say
if um okay
so let's say i look to the left first
you know this is like you know look to
your left look to your right one of you
will pass this exam kind of scenario
and i potentially add a mushroom at my
current position if there is one
if that is equal to k i j well what does
that mean that means that paths that
went to the left were able to collect
the number of mushrooms i need
to get to the position i am now so now i
can add
what well all of the different ways
maybe i'll do a plus equals
x of i minus one j
right because any path that got to the
previous guy and collected the right
number of mushrooms
can now reach me and get the right
number of mushrooms and similarly
i can look up and do exactly the same
logic so if k
of i j minus 1 plus
this number is equal to k i j
then x i j
gets an additional number of paths
like that and now i do think it's worth
spending
eight seconds thinking about our base
cases uh here
because initially when i first saw this
i panicked a little bit because it kind
of looks like this should just end up
giving you a bunch of zeros
right because like i'm just adding
values of x's to themselves i don't have
like a one plus anything anywhere
which is kind of weird if you think
about it so all of the reason why the
positive numbers appear in this problem
is from the base case which is kind of
cool
i think um it's like i think one of
these things where if you anticipated a
problem
then it's cool and if you didn't
anticipate the problem to begin with you
just wrote down this formula
you probably wouldn't even think that
it's interesting um uh but but in any
event
uh what is our base case so we'll we'll
do the b
in sort bot um so first of all um
what is k of one one remember that's the
number of mushrooms you can collect by
starting at the left square and going
nowhere
and that's zero because the problem says
there's no mushrooms in the upper left
what's x of one one well this is the
number of paths from one one to itself
that collects zero mushrooms
so that's one okay uh and i think that
the rest of the sort by
uh table here isn't terribly uh
difficult to fill in
um so notice that in in a kind of a
funny way all of these requester steps
are just adding one to itself a bunch of
times
but of course the way you do that the
reason why you get a number that's
interesting is because of all these if
statements and the fact that you can add
two different pluses coming from two
different sources
okay so i actually do encourage you guys
to look at the code in the the
problem solution because i think it's a
nice example of taking this recursive
formula and then unrolling it into like
iterating over a table
and that's a useful skill that i
intended to do today and then didn't
actually do
uh very carefully um but with that as
usual we've gone over time here so
we'll call it for the date uh and i will
see you guys
when i see you guys alright